tatsächlich gibt es ja in deutschland
immer noch leute die die afg für eine
ganz normale bürgerliche partei halten
hier apropos jetzt am kiosk kennen sie
schon das neue fdp nie sammelalbum ja
das ist super mit allen afd landi
wahrscheinlich bald für unsere bundestag
sitzen dann können sie können sie ein
kleben natürlich nur auf der rechten
seite ist klar ich bin muss ich machen
musste weil machen ja einfach mal
googlen liebe zuschauer einfach mal
googeln wer auf den afd landeslisten
ganz oben steht
der stramm nationale flügel dominierte
eindeutig mit lauter bernd hocke fanboys
man kann die natürlich trotzdem wählen
aber mit wir haben doch von nichts
gewusst kommen wir nicht noch mal durch
freunde hier mal bock auf was ekliges
wenn die franzosen zurecht stolz auf
ihren kaiser sind und die briten auf
nelson und churchill haben wir das recht
stolz zu sein auf die leistungen
deutscher soldaten in zwei weltkriegen
[Applaus]
stolz es leute fest das war doch mal den
minimalkonsens dass wir nicht direkt an
geben mit dem zweiten weltkrieg
es ist so erschütternd dass man das 2017
noch mal sagen muss aber innerhalb eines
angriffskriegs der ganze völker
vernichten sollte kann es überhaupt
nichts geben brauchen wir jetzt
deutscher stolz sein darf nichts außer
dem sortieren was passiert denn hier in
dem land ist alles nur noch schlimmer
wirklich schlimm so
den bösen alten mann klebe ich hatte mal
hinkriegen man auch im bundestag guck
mal hier der ist auch peter strohm
landeschef aus bayern findet die nazi
hipster von der identitäten bewegung
durfte und hat auch noch was zum krieg
herausgefunden deutschland haben nach
dem krieg die trümmerfrauen aufgebaut
und nicht die toten ja die türken haben
es aber auch vorher nicht kaputt gemacht
wenn die trümmerfrauen so toll sind
warum sind die hier in köln immer noch
nicht fertig einfach nur mal so zum
nachdenken
anderes thema
ja
von den aus der preisklasse sitzen weit
ganz viele dutzend den bundestag wäre es
dir hier auch noch eine kandidatin aus
bayern
mein name ist corinna metzger ich bin 33
jahre alt verheiratet
ein schäferhund
ich habe nie ein
aber hier hier hier hier ist quasi so
was wie der afg joker jens maier ultra
richterrecht ultrarechter richter aus
dresden aus sachsen hat ebenfalls einen
sehr sehr sicheren listenplatz er
erklärt den deutschen und zitiere
schuldkult für beendet und warnt vor der
zitat herstellung von misch völkern um
nationale identitäten auszulöschen
zitat ende aber er liest gerne jetzt
zeige ich ihnen mal meine lieblings
bücher die ich als kleines kind wirklich
gern gehabt
beckham war in chinesen
mecki bei den eskimos und dann auch das
mac i weil den nägeln alle gut ja alle
gut und nicht zu vergessen natürlich der
klassiker mecki bei der waffen-ss meine
damen und herren
ja ja und auch er kann auf seine
leistung stolz sein damals ich schaff
das jetzt gar nicht mehr die alle
einzukleben diese bieten da sind so
viele tolle abgeordnete dabei her frauke
petry waren diese woche quasi vor ihrer
eigenen partei das ist mal etwas anderes
würde ich sagen oder hier markus
frohnmeyer aus baden württemberg der hat
vor allem eine große fresse
[Musik]
wir sind das volk
junge junge was haben sie den dance
futter gemischt
sie hatten die allmachtsphantasien eines
einen meter zwölf großen hobbys